you wanna know a secret this boy stur
I'm about to eat most people think it's
a food safety issue you keep the oyster
alive as long as possible and that
reduces the risk of bacterial
contamination and there is a little bit
of truth to that boy stirs can carry a
scary flesh-eating bacteria called
Vibrio vulnificus you can get it from
oysters or from swimming with an open
wound in brackish water where the
bacteria lives but let's put things in
perspective the risk of running into a
bad oyster is phenomenally low my
biggest pet peeve is people like go
crazy over one bad oyster in the news
but they don't really care that hundreds
of thousands of pounds of lettuce are
contaminated with syphilis about 100
people die from Vibrio infections each
year about 450 die from Salmonella plus
the FDA requires that oyster farms have
to test water quality before sending
oysters out to markets and restaurants
and that's important because Easter's
are filter feeders they soak up
basically anything that's in the water
around them including fecal matter which
can come from rain runoff yuck but
there's a clever little secret way you
can check how fresh your oysters are one
thing that you can ask for is a
shellfish tag which every retailer or
restaurant is required to have for every
bag of oysters that they purchase for up
to 90 days after that purchase so that
tag like if they don't have it don't eat
those oysters this tag is a way for
restaurants to track where and when
their Auster's were farmed shoo says
that she looks for the most recent dates
on the tag anything further out than two
weeks won't taste as good and increases
the risk of a bad oyster some chefs may
look at you funny for asking for this
documentation but it's a strategy that
apparently works
tried to do the math and I've probably
had over six or seven thousand oysters
by now in my lifetime and I've never
gotten sick once from an oyster
basically oysters are safe so question
why on earth are they still sometimes
alive or dying when we're eating them
you really want your raw shellfish to be
absolutely fresh and you know the
freshest you can get is something that
is just very recently killed so it goes
back to not only the food safety but the
actual taste and the texture of that
oyster is gonna be just far superior
so basically freshly killed oysters
taste better and it's hard to tell
exactly when an oyster dies because
before it served its shucked and
shucking is how should I put this
shucking is not a gentle process
shucking involves separating the oysters
abductor muscle from its shell this
muscle gives the oyster control over
opening and closing the shell similar to
how your spinal cord helps you move so
severing their abductor muscle is almost
like severing your spine
yikes most restaurants in the u.s. keeps
their oysters alive on ice
up until the shucking process which
either kills the oyster or renders it
completely a mobile since they don't
move around much in the first place it's
kind of hard to tell which so it's easy
to feel guilty sitting there eating an
oyster that was either just killed or is
maybe dying
but consider the oysters biology it's
very primitive so it's possible they
might not even feel pain at all they
don't have a brain they're not really
processing pain the same way that we
process any kind of feeling so I I don't
believe that they are feeling pain the
same way that we are thinking of it so
really it's up to you if you don't want
to eat oysters that's fine and if you do
you won't be the first it's one of the
few foods that have not changed in like
thousands and thousands of years so be
able to to appreciate a food that has
remained unchanged for that long is
something really special and remarkable
and I think that should be celebrated
for what it is